der film 24 wochen ist der einzige
deutsche beitrag im wettbewerb der
berlinale und es ist ein film für den
man ja früher hätte man gesagt nerven
braucht vielleicht braucht man sogar
knochenmark vielleicht braucht man sogar
moralische fasern die sich an spannen
dabei und wir haben ein loch
wir haben eine gemeinsame nicht
getrennte klatte und haben mir ein
großes loch im körper scheinen und forum
scheidemann hier unter dem bereich
nehmen wir an kriegsmaterial julia lenz
spielt eine mutter deren kind zunächst
per diagnose vor der geburt mit dem down
syndrom diagnostiziert wird und dann
stellt sich später heraus dass es auch
noch löcher im herzmuskel hat sie steht
vor der entscheidung ob sie diese in
diese schwangerschaft abbrechen will
ob sie diese schwangerschaft abbrechen
muss der film begleitet das bis zum ende
ja man kann sagen er begleitete das ende
hinaus gespült
ich habe sehr starke reaktionen da drin
gesehen ich habe selber eine sehr starke
reaktion darauf gehabt ich glaube das
ist ein sehr mutiger film ist
rausgegangen und es sind leute drin
geblieben aber man hat wenig bisher
gesehen in diesem wettbewerb das einen
so wenig in ruhe gelassen hat dieser
film